Bonjour à tous,
Encore une vidéo de vacances format carte postale,
et euh... je voulais profiter pour revenir sur une de mes toutes premières vidéos
Celle sur le théorème des 4 couleurs.
Alors, c'était vraiment une des premières vidéos donc elle est pleine de défauts,
mais je voulais revenir dessus parce qu'elle a suscité pas mal de réactions.
Alors déjà, pour commencer, qu'est ce que c'est le théorème des 4 couleurs?
Et bien, c'est un théorème de mathématiques
qui dit que si l'on prend une carte
qui est faite de pays ou de régions, peu importe,
on peut toujours colorier cette carte en utilisant seulement 4 couleurs,
de manière, évidemment, que s'il y a 2 pays qui se touchent,
ils ne soient pas coloriés de la même couleur.
Alors ça, c'est un théorème de maths,
il est démontré, donc il est vrai hein y a aucun problème,
et ce qui est rigolo, c'est que j'ai eu 2 grands types de réaction dans cette vidéo:
j'ai des gens qui me disaient que bah non, le théorème était faux
parce qu''ils avaient trouvé un contre-exemple,
et donc, ils m'envoyaient des contre-exemples dessinés.
Et puis, l'autre type de réaction,
c'était des gens qui me disaient que mais non, de manière évidente,
ce théorème était vrai, y avait même pas besoin de faire une démonstration,
c'était l'évidence même,
et donc que c'était limite un peu du foutage de gueule que je leur raconte ça.
Alors, je vais essayer de vous convaincre que les 2 types de réaction ne sont pas corrects.
Y a beaucoup de gens qui m'ont envoyé des petits dessins,
ou qui m'ont fait des petites descriptions, en me disant que
bah, ils avaient trouvé un contre-exemple
et ils m'envoyaient généralement des choses qui ressemblaient à ça.
Voilà,
en me disant que, bah voilà, ils avaient trouvé un contre exemple,
on ne pouvait pas le colorier, il fallait 5 couleurs par exemple pour le colorier.
Et, évidemment, ce n'est pas le cas.
Y a toujours une manière de le faire avec 4 couleurs,
même si cette manière là peut être assez différente de ce que les gens avaient en tête au départ.
Et donc généralement, les gens ne voyaient pas qu'il existait une façon de le colorier avec seulement 4 couleurs,
et même très souvent avec 3 couleurs.
Alors, à l'opposé, je vous ai dit, l'autre grand type de réaction que j'ai eu,
c'est des gens qui me disaient mais que  c'était évident, de toutes façons, que ce théorème était vrai,
et qu'il n'y avait même pas besoin de faire une démonstration.
Et ce qui les faisait tiquer,
c'était notamment une des conditions du théorème
dont je parlais dans la vidéo,
qui est qu'on ne veut pas qu'il y ait plus de 3 pays qui se touchent en un point,
donc, quand vous avez 3 pays qui se touchent en un point,
c'est la situation normale, vous avez l'intersection de deux frontières.
Et donc, ce que je disais, c'est que
on veut pas, pour que le théorème soit valide,
qu'il y ait plus de 3 pays qui se touchent en un point
Y a beaucoup de gens qui disaient que, bah oui, forcément, si on impose cette condition là,
alors c'est évident que le théorème est vrai.
Alors, premièrement,
pour remettre cette condition sous une forme un peu différente,
pour voir qu'elle n'a absolument rien de scandaleux,
une autre manière de le dire, c'est que si on a plus de 3 pays,
donc, par exemple, 4 pays, 5 pays, 6 pays, qui se touchent au même point,
donc un peu comme dans une tarte, par exemple,
il suffit de considérer que 2 pays qui se touchent simplement en un point
n'ont pas une frontière commune.
On a qu'à dire que se toucher en un point, ce n'est pas avoir une frontière.
Donc, à partir du moment où on a dit ça,
on peut très bien avoir sur la carte plus de 3 pays qui se touchent en un seul point,
et on considère que 2 pays qui se touchent que par un point n'ont pas de frontière,
donc ils peuvent très bien être coloriés de la même couleur.
Donc une fois qu'on a mis cette petite condition là,
à priori, y a pas de problème.
Et puis, pour ceux qui continueraient à trouver ça évident que le théorème des 4 couleurs
soit vrai à cause de cette condition,
en fait, je voudrais vous faire part d'un petit truc.
Le théorème des 4 couleurs, il est vrai sur un plan, ou bien sur une sphère.
Et en fait, si on passe sur d'autres types de surface,
il n'est plus vrai.
Et y a un cas notamment assez amusant,
c'est celui du tore.
Alors vous savez, un tore, c'est un pneu, ou un beignet, comme vous voulez,
une bouée,
et si on s'amuse à dessiner une carte sur un tore,
et bien le théorème des 4 couleurs n'est plus vrai.
C'est à dire qu'il existe des cartes où on peut avoir besoin de plus de 4 couleurs,
5 couleurs, 6 couleurs, et même jusqu'à 7 couleurs.
En fait, sur le tore, le théorème des 4 couleurs devient le théorème des 7 couleurs.
Donc il existe des cartes, sur le tore,
où l'on ne peut pas colorier à moins de 7 couleurs.
Alors je vous ai fait une petite animation, pour vous montrer à quoi ça ressemble.
Donc là, par exemple, vous voyez un tore, sur lequel y a 7 pays,
et il faut absolument 7 couleurs pour le colorier,
parce que chacun des 7 pays touche les 6 autres.
Alors c'est quelque chose qu'on ne pourrait pas faire sur un plan ou sur une sphère,
mais voilà, ça marche avec un tore.
Donc vous voyez que ce théorème là, bah en fait, il est loin d'être évident,
et encore heureux, puisque je l'expliquais dans ma vidéo, il est extrêmement compliqué à démontrer.
Voilà! Et bien sur ce, je vous souhaite de passer de bonnes vacances si vous en avez toujours,
et puis on se retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos. A bientôt!